Dr. Peterson,
I have an interview for
medicine coming up very soon.
It's structured in the MMI format
and it's intensely competitive.
Any tips on how to
stand out from the rest?
Okay,
well the only thing I could say is that
two things.
One is really pay attention
to the interviewers,
right?
Super attention.
Like don't glare at them.
Like you're aggressively paranoid,
but like make sure you're focused on them.
And then the other thing I would
say is say what you really think,
like tell the truth.
It'll make you,
first of all,
if you tell the truth and it doesn't work,
then you know,
maybe that's not the school for you.
That's something to really think about.
Um,
and if it doesn't work anywhere
and you tell the truth,
maybe medicine isn't for you.
And I know that might be a terrible shock,
but let's assume that you are genuinely
properly motivated to study medicine.
Then tell them what you think.
You know so many people when they go into
an interview try and they do this when
they write essays too is try to tell the
interviewers what you think they want
to hear it,
but you can bloody well be
sure that virtually everybody
who's being interviewed
is going to do that and I don't think
that's very advisable because if you don't
manifest yourself the way you are,
then there's no way that the path
that's proper for you can reveal itself.
I know that sounds sort of mystical,
but I don't know how to put it any better.
The best way to stand out in an interview
always assuming you're competent and
that you've done the preparation,
you know and that you're not living a
lie is to actually say what you think and
hopefully what will happen
is that there'll be other
people on the panel that's,
that's,
that are looking at you who are of the
same type and that would characterize a
good position for you.
A good place to be.
If there are people like that and they'll
know what you're doing and that will
that,
then they'll think you know that person,
you know they're there,
they'd be good.
They're straightforward,
they're honest,
they're,
they're tough.
They're,
they can say what they think.
And if there aren't people
like that on the panel,
then I would say,
you probably don't want
to go there anyways.
So that's what I would,
that's what I would do.
Be True to yourself,
you know?
But that also assumes that you've done
your homework and that you're prepared
and all of that because if you're a
useless jackass and you're yourself,
while obviously that is going to work.
So good luck.
Good luck with your interview.
But I always think that like you,
the other thing too is don't
treat the interviewers as enemies.
You know,
if that's hard,
because if you're kind of petrified
about the potential outcome and you feel
intense judgment,
then you're likely to go in.
They're kind of afraid and nervous and,
and,
and maybe even resentful.
It's like
you've already done enough so that
you're going to get interviewed.
So in some sense the interviewers are
hoping that you'll be great already.
You know,
there might be the odd cynic in there
who's trying to figure out a reason to
give you an x and check you off the list.
But most of the people sitting there,
if they have a clue,
are going to be looking
for good candidates and
they're going to assume that
you're,
you've hit threshold.
And so it's not like
they're not on your side.
And so that's a good
thing to keep in mind too.
You're not going in there to,
to face a panel of enemies,
you're going in there to face a panel
of the sort of people that you're likely
to be in 10 years.
So that's another thing that's really
useful to keep in mind with interviews in
general.
I would say.